[Música]
aumenta la polémica alrededor del caso
del expresidente Donald Trump y la
actriz pornográfica Story Daniels la
fiscalía de Manhattan en Nueva York
acusó a tres representantes republicanos
de Iniciar una investigación sin
precedente sobre un juicio local
pendiente lo que viola la soberanía del
Estado esto luego de que los
legisladores pidieran al fiscal que
entregara información sobre el caso
también en la ciudad estadounidense de
Nueva York se llevó a cabo el segundo
día de la conferencia de Naciones Unidas
sobre el agua una jornada que giró en
torno a la asamblea general con 172
estados miembro y al tiempo discusiones
con expertos y organizaciones sociales
acerca de la importancia del saneamiento
y la seguridad
hídrica
una nueva etapa en las relaciones entre
Bolivia y chile es lo que fue impulsado
por el presidente boliviano Luis Arce
quien planteó una hoja de ruta de 7
puntos para discutir con su homólogo
chileno Gabriel borich entre los temas
está una posible salida al mar la
explotación de litio y la migración
Tenemos reporte desde tarija
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos donde el fiscal del
distrito de Manhattan Alvin lleva
adelante la investigación en contra del
expresidente Donald Trump por el pago en
secreto a la actriz pornográfica stormy
Daniels calificó como una intromisión la
citación emitida por algunos
representantes republicanos en el
congreso por otro lado el ex jefe de la
Casa Blanca Donald Trump cuestionó la
actuación del fiscal a través de
mensajes en su red social calificandola
como un plan de lunáticos de la
izquierda radical
se mantiene firme en su investigación y
cualquier movimiento de los republicanos
para defender al expresidente te verá
por lo menos ser acordado Y es que la
oficina del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan rechazó una citación de tres
presidentes de comités republicanos para
ofrecer detalles confidenciales de la
investigación contra Trump su carta con
fecha del 20 de marzo del 2023 en
contraste es una consulta sin
precedentes en un procedimiento judicial
en marcha a nivel local la carta sólo
llegó luego de que Donald Trump creará
una falsa expectativa de que podría ser
arrestado al día siguiente y sus
abogados les surgieran intervenir ningún
hecho es una base legítima para la
investigación del Congreso la
solicitudes de la carta son una
incursión ilegal en la soberanía de
Nueva York la jurisdicción de
investigación del Congreso se deriva y
está limitada por su poder para legislar
sobre asuntos federales la carta rechaza
una investigación del partido
republicano iniciada días después de que
Trump le dijera su propio arresto debido
a una investigación en su contra por el
pago de 130 mil dólares a una actriz del
cine para adultos realizado antes de su
triunfo electoral en el año 2016 un pago
que podría traducirse en falsificación
de registros comerciales fraude fiscal o
violación a la ley de financiamiento de
campañas Trump reaccionó en contra del
fiscal brack con duros mensajes en su
red social porque Brad no abandona este
caso todos dicen que no hay delito no
hice nada mal todo fue compuesto por un
loco condenado con cero credibilidad que
ha sido cuestionado por profesionales
respetados en todo momento brack se
niega a parar a pesar de la abrumadora
evidencia él es un animal apoyado por
soros que simplemente no le importa el
bien o el mal no importa cuántas
personas sean heridas Esto no es un
sistema legal esto es la gestapo esto es
Rusia y China pero peor vergüenza por
este caso se espera que el gran Jurado
retome actividades el próximo lunes
mientras los opositores al expresidente
manifestaron este jueves en las afueras
de la oficina del fiscal sin embargo
este no es el único Torbellino que
afronta el aspirante a la contienda
electoral en 2024 ya que es posible una
investigación en el estado de Georgia
por los esfuerzos de Trump para una
subversión electoral
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden llegó a Canadá se trata de su
primera visita oficial a su vecino del
Norte desde que llegó a la casa blanca
se espera que el mandatario Converse con
el Primer Ministro canadiense Justin
trudeo sobre un panorama general a nivel
internacional en el contexto de la
invasión rusa a Ucrania también Ambos
líderes conversarán sobre la disputa con
China y la crítica situación política de
seguridad y económica que vive Haití
también se espera que aborden la
migración en el continente americano
entre otros temas bilaterales
se llevó a cabo la segunda jornada de la
conferencia de la ONU sobre el agua en
el marco del evento fue publicada de la
evaluación de seguridad
hídrica a nivel mundial para 2023
realizada por expertos de Naciones
Unidas en el tema el reporte indica que
tres de cada cuatro habitantes del mundo
viven en países con algún nivel de
inseguridad
hídrica María Clara calle enviada
especial de France 24 a esta conferencia
que tiene lugar en Nueva York que nos
amplió los detalles
los desastres naturales han estado en el
centro del debate en esta conferencia
del agua de la ONU porque la mayoría de
ellos están relacionados precisamente
con los recursos hídricos ya sea por un
lado las inundaciones o por el otro las
graves sequías y Ecuador ha sido una de
las víctimas más recientes de estos con
el ciclón yaku y no solo con esto sino
que el cambio climático y el
calentamiento del planeta está afectando
los páramos andinos Y es que 16 de las
24 provincias de Ecuador quedan sobre
este ecosistema al respecto hablamos con
Gustavo manrique el ministro de medio
ambiente de Ecuador y esto fue lo que
nos dijo entre el 2022 en América Latina
y el Caribe han habido 175 catástrofes
el 88% de ellas han sido a causa del
cambio climático o temas climatológicos
Mientras usted y yo estamos hablando en
este momento mi ciudad Guayaquil está
completamente inundada y sobre ese 88%
de catástrofes que son razones
climatológicas
el 40% de las muertes a causa de eso
provienen de tema climatológico y el 71%
de las pérdidas económicas Entonces
no solo que que es que hay que salvar el
planeta sino que es un tema de perfil
social el ministro manrique también nos
explicó Qué clase de actividades están
haciendo para proteger el agua en su
país el 50% en promedio de la población
rural del Ecuador toma agua contaminada
con escherichia coli con ese fecales
Hablemos claro por qué Porque hay
actividades productivas aguas arriba que
no cuidan una fuente importante
geográficamente hablando donde se
produce agua y luego permea y abajo a
los gads les toca o tratarla o la dan
así entonces una forma de cuidar el
origen es creando una política pública
de conservación de páramos estas son
algunas de las acciones y los efectos
que está dejando el cambio climático en
América Latina el presidente de Bolivia
Luis Arce afirmó que buscará Iniciar una
nueva etapa en las relaciones con su
vecino chile Arce propone una agenda de
siete puntos para tratarlos o con su
homólogo chileno Gabriel boric con quien
espera conversar sobre un posible acceso
al mar explotación de litio e
inmigración entre otros desde tarija
Mary vaca nos dio más información
en el día del mar el presidente de
Bolivia Luis Arce ha planteado a Chile
el inicio de una nueva etapa con un
diálogo que incluya siete puntos entre
ellos la demanda marítima boliviana las
aguas del silala el litio además de
temas migratorios y fronterizos hay que
recordar que Bolivia no tiene acceso
soberano al mar desde el año 1879 lo ha
perdido a través de una guerra con chile
el presidente Luis Arce ha señalado sin
embargo que este tema es una herida en
América Latina y ha dicho que la
reivindicación es irrenunciable hay que
recordar que durante la última década
tanto Bolivia como chile se han
sumergido en un litigio internacional
ante la Corte Internacional de Justicia
de la haya Bolivia ha demandado a chile
y ha pedido que la corte le obligue a
negociar con Bolivia este acceso
soberano al mar la corte ha señalado que
chile no tiene obligación de negociar
con Bolivia sin embargo el presidente
Luis Arce considera que hay un punto en
ese fallo que que el tema está pendiente
y que tanto chile como Bolivia tendrían
que continuar negociando y en ese Marco
es que ha planteado esta agenda de siete
puntos al gobierno chileno durante esta
jornada se han realizado una serie de
actos conmemorativos en Bolivia entre
ellos desfiles ofrendas florales así
como actos políticos y militares el
expresidente Evo Morales quien ha sido
el que ha demandado a Chile hace una
década por el acceso soberano al mar ha
dicho que esta reivindicación es
irrenunciable en Bolivia
República Dominicana último detalles
para el inicio de la edición número 28
de la Cumbre iberoamericana que se
celebra entre el 24 y 25 de marzo en
Santo Domingo la capital dominicana bajo
el lema Juntos por una iberoamérica
justa y sostenible se reunirán las
delegaciones de cerca de 22 países de
iberoamérica al menos 14 jefes y jefas
de estado y de gobierno han confirmado
su participación en esta Cumbre han
comenzado a llegar para asistir a este
evento que se enfocará en reforzar las
relaciones entre América Latina España
andorra y Portugal France 24 tendrá un
cubrimiento especial desde Santo Domingo
con nuestras enviadas especiales tanto
en nuestra señal de televisión en
nuestra página web y en todas nuestras
redes sociales
es todo por el momento en France 24
gracias por su sintonía
[Música]